bang bang
lunch money time well while she's trying
to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right i guess i have a wall
street banker here with me today no
you have jeff bezos here with you today
because i lost the bet
because he didn't wear a t-shirt and
jeans like i told him to
oh wow this is what he looked like do
you remember the
mtv show room raiders yes this is closet
raiders
no it's not for those that don't know i
only have one tie
it's this one it's my favorite tie i
wear it every time that i have to wear a
tie whether i'm on television i go to
meetings or anything
it's a great time and now paulina is
trying to steal it from me yeah
i don't like that it's so large here but
we'll figure it out
we need to make it fit for me all right
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by blockfly
they've got three products you can buy
and sell crypto you can deposit crypto
and take a us dollar loan
or you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in their interest bearing account no
brainer block five dot com
lunch money go check it out what's going
on with the tech hearings
all right well the tech hearings day one
is there a day two is that it
i think that was it it happened um and
so basically
amazon as jeff bezos got grilled on
using data from third-party vendors to
make competing
and cheaper amazon products google ceo
got hammered with questions around
favoring google products or paid ads
over relevant search queries
zuck got grilled on copying features of
successful competitors
and tim cook got let off easy with the
fewest questions
mainly around apple playing favorites on
its app store
i don't understand why they're coming
after them it's kind of hard to have a
monopoly conversation when you have four
different people all
up there like who's the monopoly in
different
industries are they yeah what's the
what's the difference between what
apple's doing in amazon's doing they're
both selling products
and they're monopolizing their different
uh respective
sectors why wait can i just say okay go
on
amazon is a marketplace for digital
goods and so is apple
it's not the same why is it not best
fast isn't on amazon but
a small business is what class pass is
not on amazon class fast is reliant on
apple apple can shut it down tomorrow
but but if classpass wanted to it could
go and it could build a product for
amazon i don't okay of course it could
it could build vhs tapes and sell it the
point is that
it's comical that they're having a
monopoly conversation but they have four
different people
so how is it they're a monopoly if
you've got four people who are all
considered competitors
there at the thing and then also they're
saying well what about all these other
competitors
when the microsoft anti-trust hearings
happen it was microsoft is a monopoly it
wasn't
microsoft and three of their competitors
are all going to get dragged what's
bigger than amazon
well in the market amazon is the largest
company in the world
but in terms of it of course somebody
has to be the largest
right just naturally not everyone's
gonna be the same size but it's not
about who's the largest it's about
anti-competitive practices
and if you've got four companies that
are all worth hundreds of billions of
dollars
how are they not anti-competitive
because amazon uses uh sellers data to
help itself
so does every company okay somebody's in
a bad mood today
it's just complete nonsense and this
this was not
a uh this was not something trying to
get anti-competitive behavior
yesterday what we saw was a uh
political campaign event that's what we
saw yesterday the politicians came out
they got a shot to just like punching
bags take shots at the
tech ceos it was very obvious that the
uh political representatives have
almost no clue how these businesses work
and
the ceos are just sitting there
answering questions that are frankly
just stupid
like i literally saw a clip that polina
showed me of a guy who's like why are my
campaign emails going to spam
to the promotions folder yeah well hey
dude it's probably because you guys are
sending spam emails
like that's literally the definition of
the spam box and he asked he was like
well my dad
is getting it in his spam folder but
he's my dad why is he getting it in
there it's like you're sending it to 80
000 people
but um it was funny because i i thought
the google co answered the question
really well
if it was me i would just say hey dude i
ain't tech support
all right what's going on with gdp
where'd all the gdp
go second quarter gdp plunged by worst
ever 32.9 percent amid the shutdown
so one caveat 32.9
the the official number gets reported as
an annualized rate
so it says if you took the shutdown
in q2 uh the drop in gdp and you
annualized it it would be 32.9
that does not mean that just in q2 the
full economy contracted 32
what it means is that 9.5 contraction in
q2
annualized would end up being you know
the 32 plus percent
and so i think that's one key piece to
all this the second thing
is duh we sent everybody home
you shut down millions of businesses of
course
gdp is going to drop i'm surprised it
wasn't a bigger drop than just nine and
a half percent
yeah same agree or not if you if you
want to read more about this go to
pompluter.com
he's in a better mood there okay
uh bulgarian is getting fired today so
i'm just mad she's got my my tie on bad
mood bear
um what's going on with bulgaria what's
going on with the home front the guy has
bad the home country
bad news bears so bulgaria's
constitutional court ruled that
prosecutors can't start legal
proceedings against the sitting
president
before protesting the corruption the
sitting president
who used to be my dad's karate coach a
decision that could affect an
ongoing spat between the country's top
prosecutor
and rumen radif the head of state
so what exactly is going on there's a
lot going on
but why do they want to prosecute them
because of uh
anti-corruption inquiry so they think
he's corrupt
and what is the argument as to why you
can't charge the president
they just that's what the court ruled
the court said that you couldn't charge
a sitting president with corruption
right oh so you have to wait till he's
done doing the corruption
and then once he leaves office then you
can charge him with the corruption yeah
so if you catch him while he's doing
it he's protected it's only after he's
done then you can charge him
yeah that sounds like a really corrupt
country oh sorry
the prime minister was my dad's karate
coach the president
um has repeatedly criticized sorry the
president has repeatedly criticized
this other guy the chief prosecutor for
what he says are selective
investigations
against high-ranking officials and has
accused him of links with the mafia
which they
there's just all sorts of bad links and
bad stuff but
it's just interesting because this is
what happens when there is no democracy
guys
well it's it's interesting forget that
is bulgaria for a second it's just
interesting
the debate as to uh it's like saying to
a criminal
hey we caught you robbing the house
we're not gonna arrest you if we catch
you robbing the house
instead what we're gonna do is we're
gonna wait till you're done robbing the
house
and then we'll arrest you later well but
i
think the problem is that the prosecutor
himself is problematic
yeah oh look by the way in a country
like bulgaria and this isn't a knock
against bulgarian anyways
most your you know uh eastern european
countries like
everybody's car out that's in a position
of power so the prosecutor has got a
politicized view right and is corrupt in
many cases
so is the uh administration whatever but
but it's just interesting
the argument that they're making of like
you can't charge somebody with a crime
while they're committing the crime well
because they're if they're the sitting
president the sitting president cannot
be charged or interrogated the court
said
any existing investigations that don't
target the president can continue
that sounds like corruption in itself
okay
speaking of somebody that is going to be
interrogated
and potentially charged and also corrupt
delane maxwell so glean maxwell this is
very interesting
she um in a court filing she they're
saying that she has been the victim of a
perjury trap
by lawyers for an epstein accuser when
she was questioned
in a related civil case this is some
sort of uh legal
um so what happened basically
um uh she was improperly so
her 2016 depositions in a civil case
were improperly shared with federal
prosecutors
in violation of a judge's protective
order so they're trying to oh
and then they use that information to
charge her with perjury
so basically again she probably did
commit perjury
but the way that they got the
information this is like go back to the
example of when you
uh rob a house it's like saying hey we
know you robbed the house we have your
fingerprints on the door
but the way that we handled the thing
the process was uh
it means that we can't use the
fingerprints but and so they get off on
technicality so then
a judge a manhattan federal judge agreed
to postpone
unsealing depositions related to the sex
life of glenn maxwell
until the alleged madame can file an
appeal so they're giving her two
business days
so is this the same judge that had her
son killed
no i'm i'm being dead serious no i don't
no it's not
well remember that that was the whole
thing was there was a judge where uh she
took over par i came over if it was the
maxwell case or the epstein case and
then all of a sudden
a fedex guy shows up to the door with a
gun
yeah they open the door and they and
they shoot and they and they killed her
sonic but anyway so what do you what do
you think about this
i mean look these people are all bad
people right like
yeah but just because they're bad people
doesn't mean they don't deserve due
process and like treating them
agreed but uh any time that you get into
a
an area where people are arguing over
whether something gets released or not
and you can appeal it and
all this kind of stuff uh it just comes
down to like
they deserve to be protected under the
constitution just like anybody else
you have the right to uh be deemed
innocent before you're guilty
but like you just
this ends up being like what i would
call uh
like uh theater right theater yeah it's
just
everyone knows that there's a mountain
of evidence right including
eyewitness accounts police reports like
all this stuff now again
you're deemed innocent until proven
guilty or you know uh supposed to be
but when people begin to you abuse the
legal proceedings
and they have enough money to have
lawyers that can sit and play this tick
for tat game whatever
at some point what you realize is
they're actually wasting taxpayer
dollars right right because they're the
judge and other people that are there
now again if you've got the resources to
do it it's within your right to do it
knock yourself out
but i just personally am just kind of
like look i get it you're probably gonna
go to jail for the rest of your life
but it's also kind of probably because
you did some bad things
right and so it's just kind of like come
on but hey look that's her right to do
it she's using that right
okay yeah but what happens when they do
get unsealed
oh i mean if they unsealed all the
information these people have
come on like this is absolutely nuts
we'll see
bad people doing bad things bang bang
all right what's up with mars rover i'm
getting hot in this
um so nasa launched its latest mission
to mars on thursday
no no no no no let me be let me be okay
um let me be nice i wish i could say
that sometimes
nasa launched its latest mission to mars
on thursday roma send you to mars
sending the rover perseverance and
helicopter ingenuity
on a seventh month seven month journey
to the red planet
they are on their way let me be please i
would like to just live my life and
peace over here
uh remember we're sending a helicopter
to mars yeah that's my favorite part of
this whole thing it's very cool
thursday morning today they sent the
rover perseverance
so with the helicopter ingenuity the
helicopter
aims to be the first aircraft to fly on
another planet
mars is going to be popping soon they
got rovers they got wait wait
what rewind for a second yeah so i got a
couple of
questions okay this has always bothered
me when they say it's the first
aircraft right you fly a helicopter on
mars for the first time ever
but what i don't understand is
wouldn't an aircraft a spaceship be
considered aircraft okay but
that's one two i also never really
understood
why they consider earth the planet but
not the moon
because it's a it's a different type of
thing
i understand like like i get the
scientific explanation behind it
but the point is if you break it down to
the most basic level
you basically have this ball of energy
that has created
mass and then you've got another one you
can
okay so why does one get get to be
called the planet because humans are
energy with mass are we planets
no okay then we're humans exactly so
here's the thing
so this little helicopter will be going
up and down on mars
while all the other things are rovering
are around are we sending uh robots to
mars like have we basically sent a robot
army to mars yeah
what happens if the robot or if the
helicopter finds
like other humans humans like human-like
type well you could call it an alien but
not like a little green man but like
something that looks more like humans
than not that would be cool
you'd have a new friend on another
planet i'd call them
yo what's up man let me tell you about
bitcoin
all right what's going on this shark
attack all right so this is actually
really sad
um why are we ending with a saddle i
know well then i have a joke
um so for the the first ever
fatal shark attack in maine
happened um there was a woman 63 years
old she was killed in a shark attack by
a great white
uh while swimming off the coast of maine
and
uh people claim it's because there's a a
huge seal migration
so sh it and it's increasing in the
northeast the seals
so the sharks are following them around
and then there happen to be a human in
the way
so yeah that's really sad i know she was
a fashion
uh what was she what was she she was
just swimming in the water
yeah i don't be really messing with the
ocean yeah you're scared of that it's
not that i'm scared of the ocean inspect
the ocean yeah that's what it is
i always tell polina there's certain
things in life you just got to respect
you gotta respect the water man
you just the water you read these
stories about people drowning
all kinds of animals like for i don't
understand why humans want to go into an
animal's kingdom
and for some reason we're arrogant
enough to believe that we should
dominate
like no you got to respect the animal
kingdom you got to respect the water
just chill out look i'll go in i
basically go up until where my
chin hits the water i ain't going no
farther you ain't getting me
i mean there could be sharks there there
could be but they but we just got like a
mutual respect i talked to them before
you know y'all chill out over there i'll
chill out over here we're
good okay yeah yeah all right well
are you ready is that cool yes are you
ready for my joke
no to put you in a better mood good mood
bear
okay where did this bear thing come from
i don't know i thought you said it one
time um
she's wrong no you said it in the last
video you said bad news bears
so i need some alcohol
okay go ahead so um what do you
call a bee that's having a bad hair day
a bee that's having a bad hair day yeah
busted
no that would be good though
no a frisbee
literally my joke was funnier actually
yeah how did i come up with a funnier
joke than the freaking
stupid internet show well a frisbee for
those that don't get it plus that is
another word
in uh america for ugly it is
like man that dude's busted hmm
anyway so what do you think about my
outfit today do you think jeff
if you're watching this i'm very
disappointed he made me lose my bet i
still can't belie by the way
uh planar refuses to uh
admit that we actually bet anything she
keeps go
look at the video proof i do not believe
we bet anything
i know we bet something well what do we
bet i don't remember but i know
i don't make bets without having some
upside i think you did
i think you just did it for the
satisfaction of me saying
i actually think that what i bet was
that you were gonna have to say i was
always right
i don't think that's true guys please
tell us what we bet
all right that's it for lunch money
today
paulina is dressed like a clown because
i said normally how i dress like a clown
with my one little tie on
i am ready for washington d.c oh i don't
go to washington dc
i basically go four blocks to cnbc and
that's the only time i've ever hey
congressman
that's more like what's up joe kernan uh
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today well while she's trying to
get rich to us trying to get our lunch
money right
here's to never happen to wear ties
see you guys tomorrow i kind of like it
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends